I am going to tell you a story.
It's the scariest tale
that you can imagine.
Are you ready?
Schengen is going to disappear!
It's just a joke!
Schengen is not going anywhere.
What a weird word.
What does "Schengen" even mean?
It can be compared to a
security blanket covering Europe.
Every contact between two countries
is like a thread connecting them.
Studies have shown that
the more contacts there are
the more new ones are created.
And the more threads are created
the thicker is the
security blanket covering Europe.
Thus the warmer and cosier
it is for us to live here.
Schengen agreement means
that 26 European
countries have decided
to knock down the borders
that separate each other.
Thus it is really
easy for us to travel
whereever we want in Europe.
No border checks save Europeans
millions of hours of valuable time.
Some travel two hands in their pockets.
Some lug arround loads of stuff.
Freedom of movement across borders
has made trade between European countries
much faster and easier.
The trucks used to wait
for hours on borders
but now no time is wasted there!
If free movement of goods across
borders would stop in Europe
it would mean a lot of
additional cost to our economy.
About 30 000 Estonians,
(this is more than the people living in
Viljandi and Haapsalu together)
travel between their home and
place of work abroad frequently.
This would be much more
complicated without Schengen.
For citizens, Schengen means saved
time and simple travel
but also increased security.
The countries work together
to protect the external borders.
For example we are now building
modern infrastructure on our
eastern border with the support
of other EU countries.
The police forces of Schengen
countries work together in
close cooperation to
protect their citizens.
They inform each other of threats
and other "interesting" findings.
Our security forces
are acting as one.
The threat has been eliminated!
Now I am going to
visit a friend in Greece,
but I am going via Portugal
because it is just so simple!
Ciao!